a lot has happened to the characters of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that fan
oh snap is the stuff nightmares are made
of
so if Captain Marvel is so powerful
where has she been while all this is
going down we've got the latest theories
on her whereabouts and we'll dive into
why her cat goose has his very own
poster for the upcoming Captain Marvel
movie here's the truth about where
Captain Marvel has been this whole time
who are you who is she what the hell's
going on and can I go back to jail now
the quantum realm the quantum realm was
originally introduced in 2015 in the
movie ant-man and many fans think that
Carol Danvers has been in the quantum
realm this entire time according to the
film the quantum realm is a mysterious
dimension that defies the normal laws of
time and space Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige shared that the concept of
the quantum realm and the whole notion
of going to places that are so out there
is super difficult to fathom anyhow a
genius named Hank Pym discovered the
quantum realm while conducting an
experiment with Pym particles at first
they believed that anyone who entered
this dimension would be a total goner
but ant-man proved that that was
incorrect thanks to Scott Lang so they
made a sequel ant-man and the wasp which
focused on Pym trying desperately to
rescue his wife from the quantum realm
and remember the character ghosts whose
body was exposed to quantum energy which
caused him to be a bit out of touch with
our reality so maybe there are different
realities that are too distanced to be
affected by Thanos as snap because the
post-credits sequence showed Scott Lang
stranded in the quantum realm after the
big snap so it is possible that Captain
Marvel was in the quantum realm and
therefore immune to the thinner snap
well according to dr. Spyros Smith Lucas
a quantum physicist who is hired to
consult with Marvel on the film's the
quantum realm is a pretty strange place
dr. mitchell aqus helped the studio work
out the sciency stuff behind ant-man and
Captain Marvel
dr. Michelle akka says that according to
quantum mechanics if you can figure out
how to shrink down beyond a certain
point you become a part of a plane of
existence that doesn't abide by the laws
of physics in that place you can rewrite
the laws of the universe even time
travel is possible in this round
Misha Lucas originally came up with the
name Microverse for this phenomenon but
they had to change the name to quantum
realm for legal reasons Clerk and
dimension so for those of you who are
unfamiliar with the term Fleur Caen
allow us to explain the word Fleur
confounds like a made-up word but in the
marvel cinematic universe it is very
meaningful so what are the Fleur Caen
they are alien creatures who look a lot
like cats according to the comics these
certain aliens have some pretty
interesting abilities they can lay up to
117 eggs in one sitting and they have
the ability to extend a bunch of
tentacles out of their mouths but the
super fascinating thing about the clerk
in is that their bodies hold numerous
realities bubbles of space and time that
exists in other worlds can be found in
their genetic makeup which is pretty
cool apparently these alien feline
creatures can store entire universes in
their mouths they can access and store
an abundance of things in these
universes which they can draw upon at
will they also have these crazy
tentacles inside their mouths that they
can use as a defense these tendrils host
a nest of famed and ravenous jaws which
can devour just about anything including
Nick's eyeball we all saw that Nick Fury
had both of his eyes in the Captain
Marvel trailer and he was giving
Carole's cat goose a lot of attention
these pocket dimensions are important
that's because the sub spaces in a Fleur
khun's body can be used as portals to
other dimensions so is it possible that
Captain Marvel used her kitty cats
quantum travel device to escape the snap
that would explain why her cat has its
own movie poster fans are freaking out
about the cat poster by the way all the
cat people in the entire galaxy let out
a collective sigh over the cat's
cuteness mini fans took to Twitter in
support of this alien of the feline
persuasion they tweeted saying that
goose is already their favorite
character in the MCU one fan said that
the attention Marvel has been giving to
the cat makes her believe that gusta cat
will defeat Thanos from the looks of
that poster it certainly seems like a
possibility we can't wait to see what
this fierce Fleur can gets up to and to
find out what really happened to Fury's
eye of course
he's not a dude you're a dude
the intergalactic pager in infinity wars
there was a clue that linked to Captain
Marvel right before the snap vaporized
Nick Fury he's into message on a beeper
with the captain Marvel's symbol on it
this seems like a super primitive way to
contact a person who may or may not be
in the same dimension as you are if you
watch the Captain Marvel trailer there's
an old-school pager that shows up and
the movie is set in the 90s so maybe
that's the device she has set up for the
interdimensional communication it's not
the only 90s reference we see in the
trailer either after all she does crash
through the roof of a Blockbuster video
store for all of you kids and teens out
there blockbuster was a store that used
to rent out movies but it got replaced
by Netflix and Red Box on top of that
Carole's rocking a nine inch nails shirt
so in this context an interdimensional
pager makes sense
maybe Captain Marvel was kicking butt on
another plane maybe she was keeping
aliens from acting too crazy or maybe
she was hanging out with those
microscopic organisms in the Microverse
or quantum realm
so maybe Carole's hanging out in some
pocket dimension inside her cat totally
safe from Thanos his snack when she gets
a beep on her pager and now she's being
called to help Nick Fury in the gang out
before they all get vaporized will Carol
be able to turn back the hands of time
will she unites with dr. strange to
change the devastating events or can she
somehow affect events that have already
happened from her 1990s quantum bubble
and restore half the universe so what do
you guys think which theory is your
favorite leave your thoughts in the
comments thanks for watching the things
be sure to subscribe for our latest
videos and click the thumbs up button if
you like this video see you next time
[Music]